gerade haben wir hier noch seine theorie
erklärt dass das universum eigentlich
mit dem urknall keinen anfang hat
sondern quasi wie die erdkugel nur in
vielen dimensionen eine kugel ist ohne
anfang und ende
eine seiner bahnbrechenden theorien
stephen hawking ist tot und ich habe
einige stunden gebraucht um diese
nachricht zu verdauen
deswegen kommt das video heute etwas
später heute morgen starb der
astrophysiker in cambridge alles über
stephen hawking und warum man uns fehlen
wird jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
das war sein schicksal eigentlich sollte
stephen hawking schon viel früher
sterben so seiner ärzte damals 1963
bekam er die diagnose hls amyotrophe
lateralsklerose eigentlich hätte er
spätestens fünf jahre später also 1968
sterben sollen er hat den tod 50 jahre
hinausgezögert und in dieser zeit
veröffentlicht der absolut und
bahnbrechende arbeiten was hat 64 machte
er die unglaubliche voraussage dass
schwarze löcher auch wieder verschwinden
das war eine absolute sensation bis
dahin wurde das für absolut unmöglich
gehalten
nach ihm wurde dann auch die strahlung
benannt die das verursacht die hawking
strahlung dadurch entstand aber ein
dilemma informationen würden durch
diesen vorgang unwiederbringlich
verloren gehen 2004 korrigierte sich
hawking und konnte das dilemma lösen
seine these die informationen würden
nicht verschwinden sondern nur unlesbar
wie in einem verbrannten buch dann
begründete er den urknall mathematisch
er fand heraus dass sich die
singularitäten in schwarzen löchern
also der vermutete kritik ritze kleine
punkt in der mitte jeden schwarzen
loches genauso verhalten wie der beginn
des universums der urknall eine
singularität stand demnach am anfang
aber und das ist eine wirklich
umwerfende these das ist gar nicht der
anfang im eigentlichen sinne hawking ist
das universum nämlich eine kugel mit der
zeit eine 4 dimensionale kugel der
urknall ist dabei am nordpol
aber der ist wie bei uns kein ende
sondern nur ein punkt auf der oberfläche
er geht davon aus damit auch bewiesen zu
haben dass es keinen gott braucht denn
das universum war schon immer da und
wird es auch immer sein und zeit wie wir
menschen sie empfinden gibt es
eigentlich so gar nicht der tod von
stephen hawking hat etwas und rüstig ist
es geht ein absolut unglaublicher denker
den es so nicht noch einmal gibt und er
selbst glaubt auch nicht an gott und
irgendetwas das nach dem tod kommt
niemand wird seine stelle einnehmen
können im guardian wurde hawking zum tod
befragt und antwortete ich sehe das
gehirn als ein computer der die arbeit
einstellt wird seine komponenten
versagen es gibt keinen himmel für
kaputte computer dass es ein märchen für
menschen die sich vor der dunkelheit
fürchten hoffen wir mal dass sich
hawking da vielleicht mal der anlass
gebietet heute keine and card zu machen
rest in peace stephen hawking lief long
and prosper